bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia hoy recordaremos a propósito de
los 250 años de su natalicio a uno de
los genios musicales más universales de
la historia ludwig van beethoven
de origen alemán este compositor
director de orquesta pianista entre
muchos otros oficios que ejerció
relacionados con la música se convirtió
en un mito durante su propia existencia
según sus allegados el día en que murió
en 1827 cayó una formidable tormenta que
interpretaron como un signo de su
apoteosis su muerte se celebró como la
de un jefe de estado con el cierre de
escuelas y 30.000 personas que marcharon
escoltando su féretro desde la iglesia
al cementerio de viena
ni siquiera el emperador de austria tuvo
un funeral como el de beethoven según
cuenta román roland en su biografía la
vida de beethoven
realmente fue un día de duelo municipal
una noticia difundida en la prensa en
toda europa
a lo mejor es interesante para nosotros
saberlo porque contrarresta la idea la
imagen un tanto formada que tenemos de
un compositor aislado que habría muerto
genial pero maldito y que hubiéramos
tirado al hoyo absolutamente no la
grandeza de beethoven se construyó
durante seguidores vitorianos y
construir su vida
y beethoven es célebre por haber sido el
último gran representante del clasicismo
vienés y luego haber trascendido hacia
el hermoso romanticismo del siglo 19 en
cuanto al clasicismo que fue su primera
etapa musical siguió el camino recorrido
por compositores de la talla de wolfang
amadeus mozart y joseph haydn de un
talento innegable beethoven demostró en
un concierto de 1795 sus dotes como
intérprete eran años esplendorosos por
el reconocimiento que ganaba con piezas
de su autoría como la primera y segunda
sinfonías y los primeros dos conciertos
para piano pero durante esta primera
etapa de beethoven ocurrió algo que le
cambió la vida comenzó a quedarse sordo
los primeros síntomas se presentaron a
sus 26 años pero beethoven los mantuvo
en secreto sus sufrimientos físicos y
morales lo llevaron al aislamiento ya
naturalmente ser catalogado como un
artista maldito tosco amargado solo en
1802 reveló a sus familiares
enfermedad que padecía y el dolor que
sentía al luchar contra su imagen de
misántropo de uranio de incomprendido
del mundo
la historia le mojada al monstruo
beethoven murió completamente sordo pero
es cierto que esta enfermedad poco a
poco se convirtió casi en un beneficio
tras su muerte
ya que rescatamos de ella la capacidad
de oír lo que nadie pudo oír
o ir el infinito o el más allá en
cualquier caso estar en contacto con una
interioridad inédita para richard wagner
otro gran compositor alemán la sordera
de beethoven pudo haberlo hecho
trascender hacia una realidad musical
superior justamente la crisis que desató
la sordera en beethoven lo llevó a
entrar en un segundo período de
producción musical menos comunicativo
con el mundo exterior
beethoven introdujo el heroísmo y la
lucha como premisas de varias de sus
composiciones durante esos primeros años
del siglo 19 se destaca la creación de
seis sinfonías de la tercera a la octava
sonatas para piano como la famosa claro
de luna y su única ópera fidelio
[Música]
alrededor de 1815 beethoven entró en una
tercera etapa musical de acuerdo con
varios musicólogos que lo han estudiado
fue el periodo en que tránsito el puente
hacia el romanticismo un movimiento de
contracultura que se originó en alemania
y que le confería a la música una
estética de emociones y sentimientos
atrás quedaban las pleitesías y las
líneas que se le rendían al mundo
cortesano y al racionalismo riguroso por
delante estaba la composición de un
lenguaje musical lleno de humanidad
capaz de tocar el alma y beethoven fue
el primero en hacerlo con su novena
sinfonía
la novena sinfonía es probablemente la
obra más universal de beethoven música
compleja pero a la vez sencilla como lo
demuestra el inserto del himno de la
alegría y sus cinco sencillas notas
aptas para la comprensión y el deleite
de todo público
[Música]
el 2020 un año tan convulso por la
pandemia de coronavirus también es una
época para recordar que hace 250 años a
mediados de diciembre de 1770 nació
ludwig van beethoven un genio musical
cuyo legado ha inspirado a músicos del
mundo entero y ha traspasado la cultura
popular viva beethoven
[Música]